welcome to Horace's the channel where we
discussed the latest tech news and delve
into newest tech products today we are
taking a look at whether Ram prices will
ever go down and if this is the new Ram
price forever but before we get into
that make sure to hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to stay
updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and PCs so as you guys
already know for the past year Ram
prices have just skyrocketed and they're
75 200 dollars over what they used to
cost just a year ago and so when will
they finally go down well recently I ran
across this article on pora that
actually suggested something different
so this article suggested that Ram
prices aren't overpriced right now and
that for the past decade or so RAM
prices have just under priced and now
they're finally catching up to what they
really should be so that made me wonder
how bran prices actually always been
under priced so I decided to do some
more research and I did find that indeed
Ram prices have been under priced for a
really long time now because until now
there has always been a lot of supply
and not much demand and so prices have
really been very low there were simply
way too many suppliers and every couple
of years one or more of these suppliers
would go out of business because of
prices bottoming out here are some
examples of just this in 2009 Ram prices
were astronomically low and Kim onda
went out of business and micron bought
them this same phenomenon happened a
little bit later in 2012 micron bought
LP dough and way back in 2003 micron
also bought Toshiba so as you guys can
see this phenomenon had been happening
on a regular basis for the last few
decades and RAM companies were simply
trying to survive as it is evident for
the past few decades there have been a
lot of suppliers handing out the same
product of RAM but recently the
suppliers have condensed into just three
giants that dominate the market for
NIC's Micon and Samsung now before you
guys go on to a comment section and rage
and rant about how micron hynix and
Samsung have work together to screw up
the RAM market let's take something into
consideration first Intel's gross profit
margin is 65 percent so what that means
is that every time that you buy their
flagship processor for three hundred and
sixty dollars they are pocketing over
two hundred and thirty dollars now
microns average gross profit margin
since the establishment of the company
has only been twenty percent and now it
is at fifty eight percent which is still
less than Intel so as you guys can see
my current hasn't been very profitable
for a really long time and they're still
not overcharging you as much as Intel so
as a result this leads me to believe
that the RAM situation right now isn't
really that bad and it has just been in
a really good spot for the last couple
of years so that now when it is actually
stabilizing to where the prices should
be people are complaining finally on top
of all this the demand for RAM has been
exponentially growing the devices from
almost all categories now utilize RAM in
the electronics market so from these
businesses point of view there is
finally good demand and there isn't an
oversaturation of suppliers and so they
are finally able to make good profit
margins now these companies may seem
greedy but when you think about it from
their perspective it actually makes
sense you have barely been surviving for
the past couple of decades and now there
is finally good demand for the product
that you have been selling for a long
time so what did it make sense for you
to raise a price and actually make a
good profit I don't know that just made
a lot of sense to me but make sure to
prove me wrong in the comments down
below so maybe all that might be true
but why don't Ram companies just ramp up
the production that proves that they're
very really right well here's the thing
ram manufacturing plants don't just come
up overnight there is a lot of planning
a lot of money involved as well they're
companies that make Ram have to put a
lot of thought into whether or not they
should build
you manufacturing plan pays it costs
them millions of dollars and a lot of
work as well also even if the RAM
companies are willing to spend the money
it still takes a lot of time to build a
manufacturing plant and on top of this
ddr5 Ram is coming out relatively soon
now I'm not sure if the production
process for ddr4 and ddr5 are different
but if they are then really wouldn't
make sense for these companies to pour
millions of dollars into new
manufacturing plans for ddr4 Ram and
then in a year to spend even more money
to modify these new plans that they just
built to accommodate for DDR 5 Ram so
that is something to consider as well so
what about demand is that at least going
down well unfortunately demand doesn't
seem to be going anywhere except up so
that's all cool and all but I know that
you guys don't really care about any of
that stuff you guys just care about how
it affects you so well Ram prices ever
go down and if so when will they go down
well honestly other than some minor
price fluctuations and some deals here
and there
Ram prices aren't going to be going
anywhere at least in the imminent future
Ram prices aren't budging at all until
production of them increases and
unfortunately the RAM production
increase is not happening on top 2019 so
we still have quite a bit of time thus
we're really just stuck with dealing to
prices at least until for another six
more months and ask for the lawsuit
against the RAM companies let's be
honest here even if that lawsuit does go
through and there is proof that these
companies have been price-fixing and
even if they're finding millions of
dollars it really wouldn't make a
difference because these companies have
already made millions and millions of
dollars by a dream price-fixing if they
did engage in that
so really wouldn't make a difference for
them so finally after production
increases and there's more supply ramped
prices may drop to 170 to 180 dollars
and maybe even $150 if we're lucky but
in my opinion I do not believe that Ram
crisis will ever return back to how they
were
at like 120 to $110 but that's just my
opinion and I know you guys are gonna
disagree so make sure to go and come
with whatever you guys want like for
example do you guys think that Ram Price
has screwed forever - or do you think
that the lawsuit against the RAM
companies will make a big difference
make sure to comment down below what you
guys think because I do read all my
comments and I'm curious as to what you
guys think so make sure to post your
thoughts obviously if you guys like this
video then make sure to drop a like and
if you guys just like to make sure drop
a dislike as well also if you would like
to see more videos just like this then
make sure to hit that subscribe button
but until next time bye
[Music]